yeah so for today's data for the people
session we're going to be discussing a
paper that goes into the intersections
of koban 19 and type 2 diabetes so just
before I started talking about the paper
I just want to go into a quick outline
of what I'll be discussing throughout
this talk so first I'll talk a bit about
what exactly we're discussing and why is
relevant to us and exactly why the
authors decided to research the specific
topic second I'll be going to into some
general definitions of what exactly
diagnosed and then what a comorbidity is
and then what a significance test is
which is something that's used really
throughout this study next I'll be
talking about how exactly the authors
approach this issue so what techniques
they utilize and then I'll talk a bit
about what exactly the author's add to
the field by by a discussion of the data
that the author's presenting this paper
lastly I'll discuss some conclusions
made by the authors and in this
discussion I'll also talk about the
clinical significance of the author's
findings as well as some limitations and
future studies of this research okay but
before I go into all that I want to talk
a bit about myself so I was born in
Moscow Russia and I moved to the United
States when I was quite little oh I
moved to you Atlanta Georgia and had
lived in the United States ever since so
this is me I graduated from American
University I got my undergraduate degree
there in physics and mathematics and I'm
currently attending Weill Cornell
Medicine where I'm studying biophysics
for a PhD and recently I've really been
into just exploring New York City so
this is me right in front of the New
York City skyline and this is on the
East River in Williamsburg and I'm also
really been into vegan cooking
so here's kind of a blueberry load
that's vegan that I made recently and
I'm also this is like a really cool
vegan Korean dish that I prepared
recently okay
so first let's talk a bit about what
what this paper is about and why it's
important so this is the paper that will
be discussing throughout the talk the
title is the association of blood
glucose control and outcomes in patients
with probit 19 and pre-existing type 2
diabetes so this paper is what is known
as a clinical and translational report
which just means that it is typically
done on human participants and it's more
so directed to direct health outcomes in
the present and lastly this paper is
published in a journal called cell
metabolism and that means that this
paper is fully peer-reviewed and that
just means that it has gone through a
process where other scientists in the
fields have gone over this paper and
have decided that it is rigorous enough
to be published as scientific journal
sorry it's time to people article excuse
me
okay so now I kind of want to go more so
into what's clinical and translational
research is as compared to what we call
basic science research so first basic
science research is more fundamental and
foundational research that typically is
designed to kind of pave the way for
more applied science and medicine and
this typically involves reducing
particular problems to really their
simplest terms and then using model
systems in order to tackle those
problems so think of using different
kinds of cell types animal models so you
can make them using like lab mice for
different kinds of experiments and then
sometimes our computer simulations are
also used and then clinical and
translational research is more so
research that takes from basic science
research and then applies that to
medical projects specifically so it's
more so designed to
health outcomes correctly and in the
case of a clinical research it typically
involves a human participants and the
kind of research that we're going to be
discussing today is clinical
translational so these two being both
like really rigorous kinds of research
are very similar in many aspects so both
kind of utilize very similar scientific
research and principles as well as
pretty much the same kinds of like
research methodologies and they both
involve like really rigorous
collaboration between different kinds of
specialists especially in a field with
medicine both kinds of research really
incorporates specialists from both
fields and ultimately they share the
same goal which is the advancement of
knowledge and in the field of medicine
of course the improvement of health
outcomes okay so going back to the paper
a bit I kind of just wanted to expect
this title so again it's the Association
of blood glucose control and outcomes in
patients with carbon 19 and pre-existing
type 2 diabetes so what this Hetal is
basically saying is that it's presenting
research about the outcomes in patients
that have type 2 diabetes that contracts
the mid-nineteen and this word
association it just means that the
authors are attempting to do and compare
two groups and find some sort of
correlation between them I'm in this
case those those things being Hoban
exceed in type 2 diabetes but when
scientists want to establish
correlations the style of scientific
reasoning that they're typically using
is called a probabilistic reasoning and
this is just the use of statistical
methods in order to establish
regularities as well as identify
patterns within data trends and then
establish significance in those trends
so when scientists use statistical sorry
probabilistic reasoning again they're
using statistical analyses for
particular datasets that they have in
order to establish significance in those
data trends in a rigorous way
okay so now I'm just gonna discuss a bit
about why this research is really
important and why these researchers
published this study the first diabetes
is really a major non-comedic people
disease worldwide and actually many
scientists have called it a pandemic of
itself so kind of understanding diabetes
in the context of koba 19 is really
important given its really widespread
nature and how quickly it's been
spreading throughout the world
supplicant so diabetes is known to
present a really steep decline actually
in survivability when it's combined with
respiratory ounces so it's it's already
been known that diabetes is kind of a
really major pre-existing condition for
a lot of a lot of diseases especially
respiratory illnesses and actually a
really similar study to this one had
already been done with diabetes and the
SARS epidemic which took place in 2003
in East Asia as well as throughout the
world so the authors of this paper
really want to show on the same result
rigorously for COBIT 90 and lastly
diabetes is known to affect certain
populations really disproportionately as
was previously mentioned and this this
really represents a really serious
public health and a social challenge
when we consider koban 19 just because
of its extremely widespread nature and
how quickly it spreads and also the fact
that over 90 itself also affects certain
populations really to support
disproportionately so studying the
interactions of these two diseases is
really important for improving the
health outcomes of these communities
where these diseases have such a
disproportionate effect okay
so now I'm gonna go into some
definitions so I'll kind of define what
diabetes is and then talk about what
comorbidities are and then lastly I'll
go into significance testing which is a
technique that is used I'm all
throughout this study and here are just
some keywords to keep track of while I'm
talking about some definitions so the
first is glucose
second is comorbidity and then the third
is a significance test as well as
p-value which is a part of significance
testing okay so what is diabetes so a
really general definition of diabetes is
that it is a metabolic disorder where
the body's ability to process glucose is
disrupted and I've kind of highlighted
these two really key terms here
metabolic and glucose and what metabolic
means is it pretty much refers to any
process and that is kind of biochemical
in the body which serves to sustain life
in the body and then glucose is just a
small sugar molecule which gives energy
to your cells
so kind of using those two definitions
diabetes is a disorder where the
life-sustaining processes that relates
to glucose processing in your body are
somehow disrupted okay so now to a
better illustrate on diabetes I'm just
going to talk about what metabolism kind
of looks like in someone that is a non
diabetic so here's me so let's say that
one day I decide to eat a pizza so as I
eat this pizza it'll travel down my body
into my digestive system and it'll be
broken down into several several
different components
some of which are carbohydrates proteins
fats and several other nutrients which
which I need to sustain my metabolism
and so the the one of these that's
really the most relevance to
our discussion today are carbohydrates
which you can really think of as
molecules which kind of give your body
sort of like instant energy after you
eat food so once this pizza is broken
down into these carbohydrates the way
that your body can utilize on the energy
from these carbs is about breaking them
further down into the glucose molecules
that I talked about before and again
glucose is just a small sugar molecule
that your body can use for energy okay
so once this process happens
the glucose kind of floats around
throughout your body in your blood and
it's just kind of waiting to be absorbed
by your cells so that they can use them
for energy but the problem is glucose
actually can't be directly absorbed by
cells the glucose can't penetrate on the
cell right away so what the body does is
it utilizes a specialized organ called
the pancreas and what the pancreas does
is it can basically sense when there's a
lot of glucose in the body after you
just ate a meal for example and then it
releases a hormone called insulin
so once insulin is released and to your
body it attaches to your cells
and what happens is it acts kind of like
a key to like a locked door and then
once once this happens the glucose can
then absorb into the cell and give it
energy so what happens in the case of a
person that has diabetes so one of two
things or actually both can happen I'm
in a case with diabetes the first is
called insulin resistance and
essentially what this is is even when
insulin is released into your body and
attaches to your cells the glucose
that's uploading your blood it still
can't enter into your cell and then what
happens is your cells basically can't
get energy from glucose and then the
glucose starts to accumulate in your
blood the second thing is is insulin
missed production
and this basically happens as a result
of some damage that comes from somewhere
to the pancreas and then it's basically
unable to produce enough insulin
basically to meet the demands of glucose
absorption for your body okay so when a
person has diabetes and they develop
insulin resistance and insulin Mis
production what can happen is since your
cells basically aren't absorbing the
glucose that you get from eating in your
body the glucose starts to accumulate in
your blood and this can really cause a
lot of damage to blood vessels then
again since the cells aren't absorbing
enough glucose they may not they may not
have enough energy to kind of do the
typical processes that they would
typically be doing and over time this
can cause damage to a lot of organs
throughout your body and eventually
cause disease those organs and the most
common as a result of yourself not
absorbing enough glucose are kidney
liver and heart disease and all of these
issues are given enough time can lead to
nerve degredation excuse me which it
itself can cause a plethora of issues
get enough time okay so the last thing I
want to mention about diabetes is that
there are two main types so the first
type usually called type 1 diabetes is a
one that typically comes on comes about
as a result of genetics and it's
typically a result of some issue in the
cells of the pancreas which produce
insulin and this type of diabetes
accounts for approximately five to ten
percent of all diabetes cases okay
the second type of diabetes is usually
called type 2 diabetes and this type of
diabetes can really result from plethora
of causes poor diet can be a factor
damage to pancreas can be can be a cause
as well as genetic
and this diabetes type of diabetes is
commonly called adult onset diabetes
because it usually manifests in adults
and this accounts for approximately 90
to 95% of all diabetes cases and is the
type of diabetes that will be discussing
for the rest of this talk okay
so now I really want to define what a
comorbidity is and this is basically
just any condition who symptoms can
overlap and potentially exasperate on
the symptoms of another condition so a
pretty easy example to think about when
thinking about comorbidities is maybe
imagine someone that's suffering from
asthma so they have symptoms which may
cause them to have trouble breathing and
then let's say that they contract a
respiratory illness like the cold or the
flu so the symptoms of that respiratory
illness could potentially exasperate the
pre-existing asthma that this person has
and as you can imagine breathing can
become much more difficult for them so
we would say that asthma has been a
comorbidity for for that respiratory
illness so here I'm just kind of
illustrating potential symptoms that
could cost comorbidities for tatou
diabetes as well as could be 19 so in
the middle of a Venn diagram between the
two conditions I've listed immune
disruption vascular damage as well as
multiple organ injury and these are kind
of the most severe outcomes of both but
as you can imagine the most severe
symptoms of conditions could lead to the
most severe exasperation in terms of
comorbidities okay so now I kind of want
to pivot a bit and talk about
statistical significance and
significance testing which are two
things that are which are two techniques
that are used throughout this study
so first statistical significance is
basically a mathematical measurement of
the regularity of some observed effect
and then
significance testing are basically any
formal methods that are used to
determine statistical significance so
just a quick example to kind of
illustrate these two concepts let's say
that we're developing some medicine and
we want to test if this medicine has the
desired effect that we think it does so
what we do is we give this medicine to
one group Label Group one here and then
we give a placebo which we know
definitely does not have an effect to
another group which is group two here
and what we want to do is do an
experiment where we basically compare
the effects of the medicine on Group one
to group 2 which we know superb isn't
having any effect on them so we do this
experiment and then we collect the data
and then we put it through a
significance test and what a
significance test really is is just a
mathematical formulation typically where
the input is the data that you get from
an experiment okay and what the
significance test gives you is what is
called a p-value and what you can really
think of a p-value is basically it's a
it's a probability that describes it's
the probability that on the outcome that
you got from your experiment came about
as just pure chance so in this case we
from the experiment we let's say that we
we got that the medicine actually did
have like some sort of effect on Group
one ass compared to group two so this
this corresponding p-value we got which
is a 0.05 or four point five percent is
basically saying but the probability of
the the outcome that we got which is the
medicine actually did have an effect on
Group one just being coming from pure
chance is very low or approximately zero
point zero four five or four point five
percent and so given this p-value we can
say that we're pretty sure that the
results that we got from this experiment
is significant and then we can say that
we probably think that beyond medicine
actually definitely does have a
significant effect okay so just a quick
poll about p-values to kind of drive
this this concept home so the pulse
states given that a p-value represents
the probability that a phenomenon
happens about your chance
what p-value would we expect to get from
a significance test of something that
most probably is not a random occurrence
and the answer choices are a zero point
nine or 90% be 0.001 or 0.1% of c1 or
100% and finally D zero point six seven
percent or 67%
excuse me alright so looks like most
people said B which is the correct
answer and remember this is correct
because the p-value represents the
probability that a phenomena happens by
pure chance so if we're testing
something that that we know is
definitely not a random occurrence we'd
want the p-value to be extremely low
because that would tell us that our
intuition about that is correct okay so
going back to the key words so yeah just
keep these key words in mind as we
unravel on in our discussion so number
one is glucose which remember is the
small sugar molecule which gives your
cells energy and then comorbidity is any
condition and whose symptoms can overlap
with another's to exasperate them and
then lastly a significance test which is
basically any formal test of
significance as well as the p-value
which is the probability that the
outcome that you got came about as came
from pure chance okay so now I'm going
to go into the methodology that the
authors use in this paper excuse me
so how do the authors approach this
issue so before I get into the the exact
methodology I just want to mention that
this is what is called a retrospective
longitudinal and multi-centered study so
what do these what do these words mean
so our retrospective study is anyone
that compares students with people or
the groups differ by one or more factors
of interest and where the data is
collected prior to the analysis and then
a longitudinal study is one that's it's
one where the same observation basically
is made repeatedly over a set period of
time and then a multi-centered study is
just one that takes place in multiple
settings so keep these words in mind and
then I will come back to them as I talk
about them
ecology of paper okay so this figure
here kind of presents exactly how the
researchers started their project so
let's start at the top of this flowchart
up here so it says that nine thousand
six hundred and sixty-three patients
were diagnosed with Koba 19 and were
admitted to 19 hospitals in the who Bay
Province in China from December 30th to
December 20th so this is the initial
cohort or group of people that the
researchers started with and what they
wanted to do with this with this number
of people as they want to split split
this group into two groups one being one
with patients that had pre-existing type
2 diabetes and then another one that did
not so in order to get to these two
groups the researchers took two or three
steps where they essentially eliminated
patients who were ineligible for the
study so for example they eliminated 872
patients that did not have complete
medical records and therefore could not
participate in the study another example
about a thousand patients who were under
the age of 18 or above 75 were
eliminated and then finally after this
elimination process the researchers got
to this final cohort number of 7337 to
total participants then they split this
this large group up into two smaller
groups one that had nine hundred and
fifty-two participants and all of these
patients had pre-existing type 2
diabetes and then at the other which had
six thousand three hundred eighty-five
participants and this was the non type 2
diabetes group and by the way type 2
diabetes is abbreviated here as T to D
okay so once once the group had once the
group had this that these two codewords
what they did was they collected several
variables for all of the patients so
first they collected each each
participants age and gender second they
collected each participant's symptoms
upon admission as well as over
and then next they collected on the
comorbidities that were present at
admission other than type 2 diabetes and
then they also collected about the blood
profiles of every patient upon admission
as well as over time and blood profiles
are basically um kind of like your blood
work so they were just looking for
things in the patient's blood which were
irrelevant to the study so for example
they were looking for glucose
concentrations or insulin concentrations
and stuff like that and lastly they
collected the overall management of each
patient while admitted and what
management means is basically any
medical intervention that any any
patient had to undergo so that could
have been things like administration of
certain medicines I'm to the patients or
the use of some medical instrument like
a ventilator and by the way just to go
back to the previous three definitions
on this study is first of all our
retrospective
because we're comparing two groups here
that differ by some by some variable
that were interested in in this case its
type 2 diabetes and then its
longitudinal because we're recording all
of these variables over and over again
basically over a certain period of time
and then it's multi-centered because it
took place in 19 different hospitals
where the patients were admitted okay
okay so I'm going further
the researchers kind of donated the 952
type 2 diabetes patients further into
two groups so the first group was it was
labeled the well controlled
BG Group which B G stands for blood
glucose and in this group were patients
that had glucose levels in their blood
which were considered to be in a healthy
range and here this is considered to be
from three point nine to ten milli molar
per liter
I'm Lucas in the blood and a milli molar
per liter is kind of just a measure of
concentration and the other group was
the poorly controlled blood glucose
group and
this group had patients who had what is
considered to be unhealthy levels of
glucose in their blood and in this case
that's considered to be above 10
millimolar per liter of glucose in their
blood and then once they had these two
groups they recorded all the same
variables that I had just talked about
in the same slide for both groups okay
so once the researchers had all of these
variables what they did was they
compared all the groups that they that
they had delineating to each other on
the basis of each variable so in this
case the researchers are comparing the
type 2 diabetes cohort to the non 2 type
type 2 diabetes cohort on the basis of
medical management and in this case it's
on the use of particular drugs and they
recorded in this case they recorded on
the frequency with which each group had
to be administered these drugs so once
they had on all this data what they did
was they applied a significance test to
it and then they generated on p-values
for each instance of region since a
variable and I'm just looking at a more
specific example we're gonna look at a
drug called on systemic corticosteroids
which is basically a drug that helps
with really severe immune responses so
looking at the type 2 diabetes cohort we
can see that these patients were
prescribed on this drug at a rate of
about 29.4% compared to the patients in
the non - type a Type 2 diabetes color
which were prescribed this drug at a
rate of about 20-23 percent okay so we
can clearly see that the type to die to
be diabetes patients were prescribed
this drug at a much higher rates then
were the non - non CJD patients so now
we want to establish significance in
this data and we want to be able to say
that this is this isn't happening just
by pure chance so what the researchers
are doing is they're taking this data
and they're putting it into a
significance test
and in this case they get that the
p-value for this particular case is
actually below 0.001 or below 0.1% and
remember a p-value is the probability
that your outcome came as a result of
just pure chance so in this case that
probability is extremely low which means
that we can say in fact this outcome is
significant and didn't come about as a
result of pure chance and therefore we
can say that type 2 diabetes' having
type 2 diabetes and Koba 19 is
correlated with a higher rates of being
prescribed systemic corticosteroids to
deal with particular symptoms okay so
now we're gonna go into kind of the
results section and what the authors add
to this field okay so the first major
result of the study is that type 2
diabetes is in fact a major comorbidity
for Koba 19 and here I presented a table
where they presents the outcomes or the
most severe symptoms that the patient's
faced so in this table what they're
doing is they're comparing the type 2
diabetes cohort to the non type 2
diabetes cohort on the basis of outcome
so from this table we can we can see
that for pretty much every every severe
kind of outcome the type 2 diabetes
cohort are experienced and are
experiencing these outcomes at a much
higher rate so if we look at one
specific example which is ARDS which
stands for acute respiratory distress
syndrome which is basically a really
severe respiratory outcome we can see
that the type 2 diabetes patients
suffered from this outcome at a rate of
almost 17 17 % compared to the non
type-2 diabetes patients which suffered
this outcome at a rate of just 7 percent
and this result
when applied to a significance test had
a p-value of below there were 1% which
again means that we can correlate having
type 2 diabetes with a higher rates of
ARDS and this is true pretty much for
all of these outcomes except this one di
C which stands for disseminated
intravascular coagulation and this had a
p-value of up above zero point zero
above 0.05 so it's we can't really say
that this result is really significant
but we can't really say that it's not
significant from the from the
significance test that was done and this
this could probably be due to just like
the low number of people who actually
suffered from this outcome but in
general for the rest of the outcomes the
results were extremely significant below
0.1% okay so the second major results
from this study was that control of
glucose in the blood is essential to
good outcomes and koban 19 patients with
pre-existing type 2 diabetes and the
first the first kind of chart that i'm
gonna present for this for this results
is a similar one to the previous one and
so in this case they are comparing the
well controlled blood glucose cohort to
the poorly controlled blood glucose
cohort on the basis of medication
prescription for particular for
particular outcomes that they had so
again for pretty much pretty much every
every single medical intervention that's
shown in this in this chart we can see
that the poorly controlled blood glucose
patients had to be administered all of
these interventions at a much at a much
higher rate so again let's look at these
systemic corticosteroids so looking at
the poorly controlled blood glucose
group we can see that they are
prescribed this at a rate of about 35%
compared to 20% for the well controlled
all controlled patients and this result
had a significant p-value of less than
0.1% which means that this results was
was extremely significant and this is
true pretty much for all of these all of
these drugs some of them don't have the
most significant p-value for example
this one has a p-value of 0.5 percent
which means that the probability of this
outcome being from here chance is 50
percent which is extremely high so we
really can't say much about this but
again there wasn't really many
prescriptions of this particular drug 7
for the poorly controlled group and then
2 for the wall control group so that
that really high p-value could just come
down to not enough people on
participating in that particular
variable okay so the next thing I'm
going to present is this this graph
which I think really kind of
encapsulates the the result that
controlled glucose is really really
important to good outcomes in Koba 19
and type-2 diabetes patients so this
this graph is kind of showing is the
percent survival rates for for the well
controlled cohort patients as well as
the poorly controlled coma patients so
first to kind of explain the graph on
the x-axis is given time and days so
from day zero to a day 28 and then on
the y-axis is given the percent survival
and these numbers are in percents so it
starts from 100% and it goes to 80% so
first looking at the well controlled
cohort we can see that over time their
survival rate it's pretty study it kind
of hovers around about 98% which is
pretty comparable to people who actually
don't have type-2 diabetes who also
trafficker the 19 but then when we look
at
the outcomes for the poorly controlled
cohort we can see that over time their
survival rate actually dips down really
dramatically compared to the well
control cohort it dips down to below 95%
to about a 90% at day 28 and this is
this is I think the most significant
results of this study because it really
demonstrates that even though the poorly
controlled the pro-league Angela cohort
patients from the last slide we know
that they had more medical interventions
and ended the wall controlled group the
wall control group is still surviving at
a much much higher rate than the quality
control group so this kind of implies
that one of the most important things in
in good outcomes for coded patients with
a pre-existing type 2 diabetes really is
just good control of blood glucose and
remember healthy blood glucose in the
studies defined between 3 & 10
millimolar leader okay so finally I'm
gonna talk a bit about the conclusions
in this study and these specific
limitations as well as features studies
for this kind of research so first I'm
gonna talk a bit about the clinical
significance of the results so this is
kind of a cartoon actually from the
paper itself and I think it really
presents the most important clinical
outcome from this study really well so
it kind of depicts the previous graph in
a kind of cartoonish way so the blue
line is the survival rates for the well
controlled blood glucose covert group
and then the red line represents the
survival outcomes for the poorly
controlled blood glucose patients so
what this is kind of depicting is on the
blue line is kind of a person who is
like battling COBIT kind of really well
and they
the survival rate of 98.9% which again
is really comparable to a patient's
kovat patients who who don't have type 2
diabetes so and this I think really
demonstrates the importance of
maintaining a good blood glucose when
diagnosed with Koba 19 and then in
comparison on the red for poor outcome
line as a person who's depicted as kind
of like following as a results of Koba
19 and these individuals have a death
rate about 11% which is which is really
really a dramatic decrease from the 98.9
survival rate of those who have well
controlled blood glucose so again the
clinical significance here is that
really one of the most important things
in these individuals who have Koba 19 as
well as pre-existing type 2 diabetes is
really strict control of their blood
glucose okay so now I'm gonna go a bit
into the limitations of this study as
well as some future directions of this
research so first a really good way that
this research could be extended is
through the performance of a similar
what's called a prospective study in
order to supplement the current study
which is again a retrospective one and
what a prospective study is it's it's
really similar to retrospective studies
except that when you're comparing your
two cohorts that have some variable that
you're interested in what you're doing
is you are kind of tracking them
tracking the outcomes excuse me
in real-time rather than working with
rather than working with data that was
previously collected as an a
retrospective study okay another thing
that could be done is to increase the
type 2 diabetes code word size and if
you remember the total court size was
approximately 7,000 patients and then
the type 2 diabetes court size was about
900 which is
really really small obviously compared
to the total court size and size size of
the cohort really matters in these kinds
of analyses because the statistics that
and the researchers take advantage of in
this case really depend heavily on size
and when comparative size as in this
case is really small we can get a lot of
what's called confounding factors in our
analyses which are basically just
factors that we don't necessarily care
about but are affecting our results okay
so another thing we could do is to
understand the comorbidity between a
cope in nineteen and attempt to diabetes
at a more fundamental level and what I
mean by fundamental is more of at a kind
of basic science level so understanding
the comorbidity at like a biochemical
level at a biophysical level so that we
could potentially so we could
potentially create a really specified
specific treatments for individuals who
suffer from both type 2 diabetes and
Koba 19 and this could this could
manifest in a pharmaceutical treatment
but it could be it could definitely be
something else okay and the last thing
is to make this study to extend the
results is to make this study more
multi-centered and that is to perform it
in more diverse communities and as I had
mentioned previously both Koba 19 as
well as type 2 diabetes affect certain
populations really really at a
disproportionate rate and if you if you
remember this the current study that
we're talking about now was done only in
Roubaix in the whom a province in china
so performing a really similar study to
this one would really help in kind of
getting better health outcomes for
particular communities that are affected
disproportionately by both diseases
because these communities could
potential
have really unique factors that affect
them which don't affect other
communities so again just making it more
multi-centered would really help to its
impact and the positive health outcomes
that could possibly come out of this
kind of study and kind of just to
further that point I'm gonna present
some data about diabetes diagnosis in
the United States as deleted by race and
ethnicity so if you look on the last
three bars on this bar graph here you
can see that Hispanic people black
people as well as Native American people
are diagnosed with diabetes the most
frequently out of any other race or
ethnicity within the United States and
then this data kind of presents
something similar but with koban
nineteen so it presents the percentage
of deaths due to Cova 19's dominated
again by race and ethnicity so from this
data we can see that black and
african-american people as well as
aesthetic and Latino people make up 14%
as well as on 19% respectively and this
is data from New York State so this is
their populations in New York State but
they they actually make up more than 50%
of all total deaths despite making up
much less than 50% of the total
population so just taking taking this
data as well as the data that I
presented in the last slide and kind of
going back to why this study is really
important because obviously these this
is extremely disproportionate and again
both koban 19 and type 2 diabetes
effects these communities of color
really disproportionately so this kind
of study that kind of looks into the
interactions and intersections of both
of these diseases which again affect
these communities and disproportionate
rates is extremely important to
developing really
positive health outcomes as well as just
providing better medicine
to these communities and again going
back to my my thing about making this
study more multi-centered again these
communities can really suffer from
factors that are really unique to them
which create these disproportionality so
making this kind of study more
multi-centered and more focused on these
communities specifically can really can
really can really impact these
communities in a positive way and again
create really really amazing health
health outcomes as well as just improved
improved medical treatment of these
communities in general